So some of the first sort of systematic
experiments were done by these folks,
Wright and Guild in the 20s.
Although the experiments people know
about are a little bit later in the 30s.
They were trying to map this notion of
wavelength to perceived color, right.
So this is what I was
telling you about before,
where as I change the wavelength.
How much do you have to change the RGB
in order for you to say that they match?
And they were allowed you to be
able to say two colors are more
similar to each other
through this process, and
they define what is called
the CIE color space.
CIE actually stands for commission on
illumination or something in French, and
that's why its CIE.
So the diagram they came up with
here this is called their xy
chromaticity diagram.
Couple things to notice and we'll talk
about what x and y are in a minute.
These are the colors at,
as the wavelengths go around, right?
So you're getting longer and
longer wavelengths, right.
And you get back to here.
So the numbers around the,
these blue numbers around the border,
those are the wavelengths.
And the middle is what you get
by blending different colors.
Now what do we mean by blending?
Well, what they figured out when they
were looking at people computing
playing with these RGB lights, and other
things was they came up with a new color
space that wasn't just RGB, but
that it was going to be a linear
transform of RGB, but that the prominent
value was going to be called Y.
What does Y stand for?
It stands for luminance.
Don't ask me why it is?
Because it's actually
from the XYZ space, and
the idea is that Y is the luminance.
And so then X and Z were two other
quantities with which you be,
bet, between X, Z, and
Y you could figure out the color.
And you could represent
a wide range of colors, and
in fact in this diagram that
I was showing you before.
You notice down here it says x and
y well,
it was just this x normalized by
the sum and y normalized by the sum.
And so in some sense it's for
sort of a fixed luminance,
it's taking the luminance out of it.
And you can see as you move into the
middle oh, you can't see that at all,
because it's red drawing on red.
As you come to the middle
you're blending all these and
that's going to be white and we'll talk,
or gray depending on the luminance and
we'll talk about that in the minute.